people who live in the country can't
afford to drive their cars or buy
groceries
but no one in washington seems concerned
about this the economy is fine as far as
they're concerned in fact democrats say
it's a perfect time to splurge
for real our own bill malugion is
tracking this story for us hey bill
hey tucker that's right so there's an
assortment of media figures and
politicians alike who seem to be telling
americans just don't believe your lying
eyes when it comes to the prospect of a
recession and the chairman of the
federal reserve certainly doesn't seem
too worried as he was literally
whistling around washington today as
fox's hillary vaughn was trying to
question him take a look
should the president stop calling it
putin's price hike you told lawmakers
yesterday that inflation started well
before the war in ukraine so should he
stop saying it's putin's price hike
and on top of that washington post
finance columnist michelle singletary
demanded that americans who are doing
well just everybody calm down and back
off when it comes to inflation take a
listen you've got to stop complaining
when there's so many people who
literally the inflation rate means they
may only have two meals instead of three
there are americans who did extremely
well in the last two years in the market
you still have your job and yeah it's
costing you more for gas but guess what
you're still going to take that holiday
that fourth of july vacation you can
still eat out so i'm gonna need you to
calm down and back off but overall many
americans are not suffering as much as
they think they are
and not to be outdone msnbc stephanie
rules said it's the media's fault for
talking the u.s into a possible
recession
another thing the fed can't do though is
control media hype or political agendas
in some ways we're talking ourselves
into an inflation frenzy when you talk
about it every minute of every day then
every possible business out there raise
their prices why because they can
because no one's going to argue why are
you raising that price inflation
inflation inflation
and if you can't afford your gas or your
groceries there's no need to worry
democratic congressman ed perlmutter
says you can just get a peloton for much
cheaper now take a listen i think all of
us would agree we don't want to see
inflation but we went through a pandemic
and we've had shortages so you could go
get a peloton today
at half the price you would have paid a
year ago mr style and i said i will
you can't eat
and tucker on top of all of that the la
times wrote an article saying a
recession looks inevitable but it might
not be that bad there was an opinion
piece in bloomberg that said inflation
is just a lesson in appreciating what
you had instead of complaining about
losing what you had and the new york
times wrote a piece saying a bad economy
might end up actually being a good thing
we'll send it back to you
you learn nothing and you'll like it eat
your bugs half price pelotons
you can't
i assume all that's real bill malugen we
trust you
that's unbelievable thank you
thanks
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight